what has it been like for twilio during
this crazy pandemic obviously we're
taping this
as the delta variant seems to be waning
we can only hope and uh we almost got
there on vaccines so close but
yeah yeah well you know you know it's uh
as you said it's an acceleration right
which is the trends that have driven
digital adoption and you know what
people call digital transformation
these things have been going on for the
last 15 20 years
you know they got accelerated by
mobile phones and smartphones they got
they got started many ways because the
web
well covet accelerated those trends even
more right because we become even more
uh reliant on these digital workflows of
getting things delivered to us instead
of going face to face of buying things
online instead of offline
and it's interesting even trends like
seeing a doctor via video
i think have
experienced a one-way acceleration which
is you know telemedicine you know was
not invented during the pandemic it had
been around for a while but
you know most of our habits were like oh
when i need to see the doctor i go to
the doctor that's what i do
well along came the pandemic and many
people had their first telemedicine
visit for one reason or another whether
it's just a you know well regular
checkup or a scrape or whatever it is
you saw a doctor via video and you
realize oh wow
like that was so much more convenient if
i need to see a doctor you know i don't
have to call and schedule and then take
uh take half day off of work drive
across town find parking sit in the
waiting room where i assume i'm getting
more sick you see being in the doctor's
waiting room yeah like all i need to do
is take 15 minutes out of my calendar
and uh join yet another zoom right
basically right and see and see the
doctor
and how much more convenient that is and
i think the net result of that is more
people are going to get health care
you're not going to put off that
appointment or for folks
especially those in rural areas they
will be able to see the doctor that they
couldn't see or imagine folks who are
um who are hourly workers where seeing
the doctor literally means going without
salary right because you need to take a
day off of work and imagine if your kid
needs to go to the doctor and you need
to drive to like across the state
and to you know to find that specialist
and take days off of work and go without
your wages imagine all the medical
appointments that just don't happen
how's that anyway this is just one
example but i think it's such an amazing
one because the acceleration of
telemedicine is just one example um this
is a one-way street like these
experiences that we have had we've
realized just how powerful they are how
they give us back time how they
make us more efficient
and that you know we did a survey of a
few thousand companies
recently and we asked them
how much did kovitt accelerate your
digital strategy
and on average
the digital roadmaps of companies were
accelerated by six years
wow six years
and that's backed up by some of the
conversations that i've had with folks i
was talking with the
cio of a major big box retailer
and you know this was last year and and
the cio said
we saw
a
for him this was like mid last year he
said we saw a five-year acceleration of
our e-commerce adoption in the course of
one quarter
wow you can imagine just how companies
have to pour resources in to support
that growth to support their customers
and that has been just a critical
acceleration i remember
that weekend
remember the weekend where just really
everything shut down yeah that was like
the i think it was the 12th
friday the 13th i'll never forget it it
was friday
i think it was the 12th that the nba
cancelled the game with people on the
court and was like everybody go home and
you're like go home
yeah wow that's dramatic
that week it was the week of march 9th
2020 when just everything just got so
real uh here in the united states at
least
and
and that weekend so i was actually on a
work trip that week i got home and it
was like okay we're all going into
lockdown and like you can imagine like
you know every executive team of every
company was having calls like okay what
are we what's going on what are we doing
we had shut down all of our offices uh
early that week
and you know there were real questions
raised of like okay like should we stop
hiring should we do you put a pause on
all because who knows what's about to
happen right
and an interesting thing happened that
weekend
i got so many emails
from developers
customers
partners
non-profits
you name it
people say i'm building a thing and
building a thing to help kids homeschool
and building a thing to help keep uh you
know patients out of hospitals that are
that are going to get overwhelmed i'm
building a thing to help keep people
safe or keep track of loved ones
so many ideas suddenly we're coming out
of the woodwork and everyone was saying
hey you know jeff yeah can you hook us
up with credit can you find us help
anyone know how to do this or and in
that moment
i realized just how important the
builders of the world
were going to be
to help us all manage through this
pandemic
yeah
and
in that moment we decided it was like we
are not going to freeze hiring in fact i
think we're going to grow we set a goal
for the company we said our goal is to
emerge stronger from this pandemic
it's time for another r crowd deal of
the week right now you can join our
crowd's investment in orient according
to the deal memo orients software only
indoor gps is 20 times more accurate and
scalable than current solutions and
they've landed contracts with some of
the world's largest retailers so why
join our crowd well our crowd investors
were early in some of the best
performing ipos of 2019 and 2020 and now
you can join them with our crowd
accredited investors can invest directly
easily and most importantly early our
crowd investors have benefited from
companies ipowing like beyond me or
being bought by companies like intel
nike microsoft oracle and my personal
favorite uber so here's your call to
action our crowds accredited investors
have already invested over 1 billion
dollars in growing tech companies
if you are an accredited investor you
can join our crowd for free at our
crwd.com
twist and review the current deals
there's no payment involved until you
decide to invest that's ourcrowd.com
twist to sign up for free